[Music]
a lot of my work is around corporate
income shifting which is one way that
companies respond to tax incentives
globally so if you think of a company
that has all of its income across all of
its operations around the world
it's going to be taxed on that income
and each jurisdiction and so if there
are different tax rates in different
jurisdictions which we know there are
then it's in the best interests of the
company from a tax planning perspective
to try to report more profits in low-tax
jurisdictions and less profits and high
tax jurisdictions
I like to think of it as first and
foremost an operational decision so
where as a company do you put your
footprint around the world such that
you're creating value in different
jurisdictions and this is something that
gets a lot of attention in particular
with intellectual property patents and
things like that
putting those in low tax jurisdictions
sometimes called tax havens and that
allows a lot of the profits to move be
reported in those low tax jurisdictions
but it's it's a broader analysis than
just intellectual property it's all of
the functions risks and assets of the
company and so the operational decision
is figuring out a tax efficient
footprint and then on top of that you
can layer an accounting decision and
that is now that I put some patents in
say Ireland how much of a royalty do all
of the other parts of the company have
to pay to my Irish subsidiary for the
right to exploit that intellectual
property and that fundamentally is it's
an economic question but it gets into
the accounting space of exactly how we
want to assign a price called a transfer
price between these two subsidiaries and
where does that allow us to report our
profits from a tax perspective
there's a global set of rules and each
country has its own set of rules - for
how you're supposed to come up with what
that price is
and the fundamental principle that we
operate in globally not all countries
but most countries these days is called
the arms-length standard so it's
supposed to be a price that you would
observe out on the open market between
two completely unrelated parties so if
you and I were transacting for the sale
of shoes or whatever it is right that
would be the price as long as it's at a
similar level of the market so wholesale
versus retail in a similar economy you
can take into account nuances like
developing economies and foreign
exchange rates and things like that but
it's supposed to be as if we're
operating at arm's length
the problem with that is that a lot of
these services and products that
companies are transacting with it
amongst their own subsidiaries are not
the same types of things that unrelated
parties transact so it's not often the
case that a company that exploits its
own intellectual property around the
world is going to also license that out
to unrelated parties as one example
another example is you think of a CEO
providing high-level strategic
management for all of the operations
worldwide that person is not also
providing those services for competitors
for example so it can be very difficult
to observe an arm's length price and
that's what provides a lot of discretion
to companies to try to establish a price
substantiate it defend it but also a
price that's going to work for best for
them from a tax perspective and this is
the big question that we're seeing these
days internationally a fundamental
question about transfer pricing should
arms-length be the right standard or
should it be more closely aligned with
where the physical footprint of the firm
is so discounting intellectual property
a little bit from from how much it
matters today and focusing more on where
sales are made where the customers are
and where the actual employees are
it seems tempting I think for countries
to set their tax policies in a way to
try to mitigate this on a unilateral
basis you know or they're acting in
their own best interests
but given globalization and just the
increasing amount of dealings that are
happening across borders I don't think
we get to a long-lasting answer until we
get countries cooperating trying to
harmonize tax laws it doesn't have to be
the same rate but at a minimum we need
to agree on how these cross-border
transactions should be priced where
profit should be recognized and until we
do that you're going to have companies
and individuals taking advantage of
differences
there's a lot of research indicating
that companies are shifting income they
are making operational and accounting
decisions to move income out of high tax
locations and into low tax jurisdictions
what's interesting about one of the
studies I have is that a lot of the
other research out there ignores one
major tax strategy that companies can
take and that is taking advantage of
their subsidiaries with losses which is
a really really important tax strategy
to companies when we include this
important strategy we find that the size
of the effect is actually much larger
than we thought before actually all of
the research out there could
underestimate the amount that
corporations are engaging in this income
shifting activity by as much as 50
percent which is a very big difference
so there's a lot more of it going on
than we thought and it's a lot bigger
than we thought
what does it mean to pay your fair share
whether it's a corporation or an
individual what does that look like what
does it look like to be a good corporate
citizen or a good citizen of of your
country where you owe taxes and it's a
tough question
because companies have a profit motive
they have shareholders that they're
beholden to and there's a perspective
the shareholder perspective of the firm
that companies should be maximizing
value for those shareholders there's
also a stakeholder perspective which is
that we're all stakeholders in this
society that we've built and so we
should all pay our fair share and I
think the two perspectives aren't
necessarily mutually exclusive but it's
very difficult to answer the question
what is fair because it's inherently
subjective if we know that companies are
doing this and we can estimate how much
they're doing it and we're starting to
look at what some of the consequences of
that is it's natural to ask what should
the policies be to think about what
could be done to mitigate the behavior
if we think it should be mitigated or
just generally you know how should
corporations be responding is there a
policy tool that we can use to try to
get that response instead of what
they're doing now
[Music]
you
[Music]
you